doucement plus qu'un jeu le bowling est
un véritable exercice pour luna tenir
une balle synchroniser ses mouvements
autant de difficultés lorsque l'on est
atteint d'infirmité motrice cérébrale à
neuf mois les médecins estimaient
qu'elle ne marcherait jamais mais grâce
à ces séances de kiné elle arrive
maintenant à se tenir debout et se
déplacer si luna en est à ce niveau
aujourd'hui c'est grâce à sa
persévérance patienter motivé la petite
fille de 11 ans investit dans chacune de
ces tâches elles arrivent en classe de
bonne volonté et que c'était donc sa
participation est généralement très
bonne ils ont au sein de l'établissement
même tout un tas de rééducation
ergothérapie psychomotricité kiné etc
donc c'est des enfants qui sont cons
faculté d'adaptation énorme ici tout ce
qui est rattachée aux scolaires est
appliquée dans la vie quotidienne pour
un apport concret exemple avec cette
recette de crêpes qu'elle remet dans
l'ordre une fois la maison luna met en
pratique avec sa mère l'enjeu de tous
ces exercices est le même la rendre plus
autonome mais sans objectifs précis
j'attends rien je veux juste lui
faciliter les choses et et améliorer son
quotidien
je vais poser une question une fois de
savoir si elle était heureuse même en
étant handicapée elle m'a répondu que
oui c'est ça et je lui ai demandé si son
handicap lui poser un problème elle m'a
répondu non
la chose la plus importante c'est
qu'elles soient épanouis dont l'ordre
dans son handicap en épanouissement qui
passe aussi par le matériel ses
différents équipements lui permettent de
se déplacer ou de communiquer plus
facilement avec les autres comme cette
synthèse vocale qu'elle a depuis trois
ans ça permet d'avoir à s'exprimer et
aussi pour pouvoir apprendre à lire et à
écrire
c'est important en fait qu'elle entende
les mots
quand l appui de g en dehors de la
maison et de l'école luna pratiquer
différentes activités
elle va à la piscine chaque semaine et
pour la première fois elle se met à la
guitare
un moyen de s'amuser pour nous n'a qui
adore la musique et surtout de
solliciter sa main droite qui
n'utilisent que très peu habituellement
on a surtout travaillé avec la main
droite pour essayer de voir qu'elle
commence à bouger un peu la main droite
pour faire des notes et moi j'ai fait
quelques accords avec la main gauche
pour que ça commence à sonner à faire un
peu de musique est arrivé on a fait
quelques on a fait un peu d'accord
exactement avec le pousse donc donc on y
est arrivé c'était bien on a vraiment
envie de montrer que le handicap c'est
pas ce pas une tare on peut vivre avec
un handicap on peut faire des choses
luna a hâte de faire de la moto par
exemple ou faire du saut en parachute et
je pense qu'on le fera de toute façon un
nouvel équipement est en cours
d'acquisition pour aider luna a marché
des appareillages pouvant aller à plus
de 7000 euros pour pouvoir le financer
corinne organise des événements au
profit de son association un geste en
plus fin avril aura lieu un concert rock
à l'iufm de bail
moore